what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
getting hyped up over the latest events
in the incredible and ongoing boku no
hero war arc including the epic entrance
of sun-eater tokyo me and phat gum not
to mention the deadly showdown between
twice and hawks that was just
interrupted by an unhinged dobby things
are moving very quickly and a top ranked
pro hero's life is now in direct and
imminent danger I can't wait to talk
about it all right here before we get
into it a massive thank you to Bleach
immortal soul for sponsoring this video
we just got the huge news that the
Bleach anime will be returning in 2021
and if you're excited but you still need
to get your bleach ego fix in the
meantime check out bleach immortal soul
the OL new RPG mobile game which is
officially authorized and licensed by
the Bleach animation production
committee with this game you can relive
the classic stories of the Bleach anime
featuring the original voice actors and
you can engage in exciting battles using
all our favourite characters you can
unlock and collect all your favorite
bleach heroes and you can use them to
create amazing combo moves that really
wreak the hollows you can play story
mode player versus player battle arena
and more the game has strategy action
and a ton of nostalgia check it out for
yourself the game officially launches on
March 26th on both iOS and Android you
can redeem this special code for awesome
bonus prizes just click the link in the
description or go to patron da mãe slash
bleach uproar by trying out the game for
free you are supporting the Bleach
official release and you are supporting
this channel so go ahead and check it
out
patron da mãe slash bleach uproar or
click that link in the description
please be advised that this video will
contain boku no hero manga spoilers I'm
talking about the very latest events in
the story so please proceed with caution
you have been warned the chapter starts
off with phat gum
our boy sun-eater and the chicken of
darkness talk lay on me fighting it out
at the villain mansion fat gum and
sun-eater confirmed that all of the
alternate exits that lead out from the
mansion have now been blocked by the
heroes and so now the only way to exit
the underground complex is through one
of the five exits that go through the
mansion itself since there are seemingly
hundreds of villains currently located
inside the underground complex just
beneath the mansion the heroes want to
trap as many of them as possible
underground
however cement osseous quirk cannot
reach these passageways
so it is up to the heroes to go in and
block off as many passageways as
possible it is only now that we realize
just how valuable Hawkes is Intel was
for this entire mission
Hawks didn't just tell the heroes about
the hospital and the mansion he also
told them about all of the secret
passageways and alternate exits which
I'm sure were considered to be top
secret by the villains and I don't
imagine that these secret passageways
would have appeared on any Maps or
blueprints
not to mention that Hawks instructed the
heroes to attack at a time when hundreds
of villains would be trapped underground
making the job of the heroes that much
easier without Hawks none of this would
have been possible he is definitely the
star of this entire war arc when you
really think about it Sun Eater uses his
quirk to transform into some massive
hybrid animal creature he grows horns on
his head and his lower body appears to
turn into the body of a bull so
sun-eater practically turns himself into
some sort of center slash Minotaur
hybrid who also happens to have tentacle
shaped outgrowths on his hands which he
uses to whip the crap out of the
villains let's be real if I saw some guy
with the body of a bull and with vines
and tentacles popping out of his arms
charging right at me I would get out of
there real freaking fast sun-eater is no
joke we've seen him transform before but
this vast hybrid chimera transformation
is on a whole nother level from anything
we've seen him do so far this man
definitely has the potential to become
one of the most
powerful pro heroes in Japan as fat gum
and sun-eater cover for him Tok Li ami
moves into one of the underground exits
with the intention of closing it shut he
unleashes dark shadow and uses a move
called Ragnarok to absolutely ruin the
villains day read estro is able to power
up and use his quirk to offer some
resistance to dark shadow but this
resistance doesn't last very long and
Takayama quickly succeeds in sealing up
the exit by making everything crumble
into rubble
Takuya me is actually surprised that
read estra was able to do even that much
against his dark shadow Ragnarok attack
but then dark shadow itself proceeds to
warn Takuya me that there is a real
monster down there in the underground
structure the monster that dark shadow
is talking about is giganto macchia who
truly is an unstoppable machine of
destruction but fat gum says that even
though giganto macchia is incredibly
powerful he most likely won't do
anything this is because gegen to
macchia needs an order before he acts
and the people that give him orders such
as all for one ug co and shigaraki are
all busy with their own problems at the
moment then in a hilarious twist fad gum
stuffs Doku yummy inside his belly fat
presumably to protect him since tokyo me
is still just a first-year student I
have to say that toki ami looks adorable
with only his head popping out of fat
gums massive belly it's so funny to see
the brooding dark gothic Takuya me
looking like a cute little baby bird
inside a nest of fat gums fat but as
funny as this looks it does make sense
the heroes need a Takumi's powerful
quark to seal off one of the main exits
from the underground to the mansion but
even though toki ami has an all peak
work he is still an unexperienced
student and not a pro hero so with that
in mind the heroes still want to protect
him as much as possible even though they
needed him to join them on the
frontlines but in that moment
tokoha he says something interesting and
something that has been bugging me for
quite a while
he asks fat gum don't
think that this mission is going a bit
too smoothly
Fatima explains that this is because
Hawkes succeeded in infiltrating the
enemy group and he was able to provide a
lot of great Intel for the heroes and
that is all true but even so I do think
that toh kweh ami has a point all of
this has been going a bit too smoothly
for the heroes and I am certain that
some major complications are coming if
for no other reason than because let's
face it everything going smoothly
doesn't make for a very good story
if these hero raids succeeded without a
hitch and all the villains including
shigaraki just got crushed before they
had a chance to counter-attack then this
would be a great outcome for the heroes
but not the most interesting outcome for
the readers I am certain that the
villains are about to get their footing
and counter-attack successfully which
will throw a major wrench into the plans
of the heroes frankly it's just a matter
of time we all know that that will make
from much more interesting story with a
lot of ups and downs and twists and
turns although it will also put the
heroes in great danger as taqwa he
thinks about his mentor Hawkes and how
Hawkes inspired him to become a hero the
chapter shifts to Hawkes himself who is
using his many feathers to destroy twice
as clones faster than twice can create
them twice his speed when it comes to
creating clones is incredible but Hawkes
also has unbelievable speed and because
twice is under a lot of pressure he
cannot seem to generate enough strong
clones rapidly enough to overcome Hawkes
his attacks we all know how overpowered
sad man's parade is so the fact that
Hawkes is able to keep twice at bay
speaks to how strong Hawkes actually is
his power and his speed cannot be
underestimated Hawkes tells twice that
he offered him a chance to be captured
peacefully but now because he continues
to resist Hawkes says matter-of-factly
that he won't hesitate to kill twice if
it comes down to that but as we all know
twice is driven by his loyalty to his
friends and he is willing to do and risk
everything and anything to protect them
twice even creates clones of his League
of villains calm
but hawks quickly dispatches them along
with all of his other clones twice is
furious and he absolutely refuses to
give up and Hawkes knows that a villain
who never gives up is a hero's worst
fear guys like that will never stop
putting up a fight and for villains like
that the only solution is to kill them
to him Hawks is a dark and very
pragmatic character it seems to me that
most heroes are committed to always
bringing the villains in alive and the
other heroes never even talk about the
possibility of outright killing someone
but Hawkes has no fancy idealistic
beliefs about being a hero he knows that
sometimes you have to kill the villain
before he kills you and that's just the
way it goes
Hawks then completely overpowers twice
which is understandable now that twice
is so emotionally unstable and
distraught and hawks then prepares to
end twice his life as a sharp feather
hangs right above his face twice again
blames himself for putting the league in
danger for a second time and he explains
that all he wanted was to protect
everyone's happiness Hawk says that he
will pass this message along to the
League of villains after twice passes on
but Justice Hawks is about to end twice
his life dobby shows up and blasts Hawks
with his epic blue flames well they're
not blue in the manga since it's all
black and white but I could just imagine
them being a searing flaming blue dobby
says that there is no need for hawks to
play the role of a messenger because he
heard twice his message loud and clear
and so Dobby proceeds to make some fried
chicken right then and there
as hawks lies injured on the ground
burned by doggies flames Dobby stomps
down and hawks his head with his foot
and he asks Hawks how come he didn't see
him coming didn't Hawks say that he
doesn't make mistakes and yet he didn't
anticipate that Dobby would be here so
soon and that is how the chapter ends
with the table's turned and with hawks
his life now in imminent danger instead
of twice's Wow we all knew that Dobby
was coming we
in the previous chapter but I don't
think that any of us were prepared for
the tables to be turned so drastically
and so quickly as I said Dobby just made
Fried Chicken in record time and as I
warned in my previous boku no hero video
Hawks might become the first hero to
lose his life during this raid it really
seems to me like Dobby suspected that
something was going on with Hawks I
don't think he knew for sure but I also
don't think that he just accidentally
showed up in this precise moment at this
precise time and just having to stumble
upon Hawks and twice Dobby was always
suspicious of Hawks ever since the
beginning of Hawk says pretend the
partnership with the villains although
to be fair Dobby doesn't really trust
anyone because of this distrusting
nature it is possible the Dobby secretly
kept an eye on Hawks from the shadows
and so it is possible to Dobby sensed
that something was happening with Hawks
before any of the other villains
realized it this would explain why Dobby
made his appearance in this specific
moment in such a deliberate way and why
he expressed no surprise whatsoever at
the fact that Hawks was attacking twice
Dobby doesn't feel shocked or betrayed
at learning that Hawks was a double
agent who is now trying to kill twice
Dobby just jumps into action right away
and burns our young Icarus without a
second thought
all in all this chapter featured a ton
of action and I enjoyed it a great deal
I love that we got to see sun-eater and
Takuya me on the battlefield dark shadow
continues to be freaking awesome and
Ragnarok looks incredibly opie I also
thought that fat gum holding takla me
inside his stomach fat was pretty damn
precious in a very manly badass hero
sort of way of course so now it's time
for you guys to tell me what you think
is going to happen is Hawks going to be
killed by Dobby or is another hero going
to intervene and save Hawks right in the
nick of time
also what is going through Dhabi's mind
right now is Heymann concerned above the
hero raid or does he have some sort of
secret plan already in place he
certainly doesn't seem very worried or
surprised to me but then again Dobby is
not
your average person so who knows whether
he actually has a plan or whether he
just enjoys a good hero hunting
challenge we'll have to wait and see if
you enjoyed this video you want us to
keep it go and please leave a like to
let me know it really does help and if
you have it to be new to anime uproar
please don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications don't forget to check out
our epic sponsor bleach immortal soul
just click the link in the description
and try to game out for free to enjoy
the bleach awesomeness as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see us space cowboys
[Music]